hey grammarians today we're going to be
talking about correlative conjunctions
and I know this looks like a pretty ugly
word correlative like it's kind of
complicated looking but let's break it
down this Co part comes from a Latin com
meaning with or together and relative
when we know what the word relative is
like your aunt or your uncle or your
cousin is a relative so we're just going
to say that just means relative or
related so correlative conjunctions
there we see it definitional ER or
analogically are related together in
some way there they're matched pairs
they're a matching set and this just
means that when you see one it's
probably time to use the other in this
video we'll go through five of my
favorites so either/or is a good pair to
start off with and when you start a
sentence with either or either I don't
know how you say it
it sets up the expectation that you're
going to have to be choosing between two
things so we're going to say or later in
the sentence as in what is reputed to be
Oscar Wilde's last words either the
wallpaper goes or I do the opposite of
either/or is neither nor so either/or
sets up this choice between two options
and neither nor rejects both options so
neither gian or Becca liked Howard and I
recognize that I say neither and some of
you say neither and there's a whole
George Gershwin song about that but
let's just chalk it up to my Midwestern
American accent how about either either
neither neither let's learn about some
conjunctions but oh if we talk about the
both then you use and and oh if you
learn to use conjunctions that is grand
oh yes both big BM that do were career
criminals while we're using both to
indicate a connection between two things
and then we use and later in the
sentence to really firm that up as so
it's kind of an interesting one it's a
little formal and it kind of allows you
to set up this
relationship of consequence right to say
if one thing is happening then another
thing happens as a consequence so as
goes Kansas so goes the nation so you
know as as one thing happens so must
another thing happen is what this is
trying to set up whether and/or is
similar to either an or except it has a
kind of width of possibility about it
whether you like shrimp or chocolate
there's certain to be something for you
at the Veracruz Food Fair right because
weather is kind of setting up this
possibility between these two options
and it doesn't really matter which one
you choose there's just a it's just
offering up possibilities and I would
like to offer you the possibility of
checking out more of these correlative
conjunctions in our exercises so stick
around you can learn anything Dave it
out